(calming music)
- The first time I really
took a horse in the water,
I had a friend that had
horses on the north coast.
Her house was right on the beach.
We set up some little jumps and we were
going over with her horse.
And she said, "Oh, it's too hot.
It's too hot.
We've got to take the horse in the water."
I said, "We can't take the horse in the,
in the sea like that."
She said, "Yeah, sure.
Come on, jump on."
(calming music)
You know, the waves were coming in
and the horse just sort of lifted his head
and the waves would come over.
And we just went in a little bit deeper
and a little bit deeper and
then he started swimming.
(calming music)
You can ride all your life
and you've never felt that smoothness,
that, that power but with no uh,
there was no jolt at all.
It was just so absolutely like silk.
(calming music)